all right and next call we're gonna do
something a little bit different
we've got lindsey and xander we're gonna
take a couple's call so first on the dr
john dolone show
lindsay and xander you guys there yes
sir
how are you i'm hey i'm great my
marriage isn't on the line here so this
is awesome
thank you all for being brave and for
giving us a shot here
and to all the listeners we're trying
something new and i want to just
shout out lin lindsey and xander for
their willingness to call here
um so hey how's it going y'all doing all
right
doing pretty good awesome how about you
man
i'm better than i deserve oh well played
i like that all right so
let's do this um lindsay give me a
three minute or so explanation of what's
going on
and then xander i'm going to ask you to
give me your explanation of what's going
on
and y'all are in different cities right
yeah different states
oh different states even better so
here's what's important
you both have to be completely
vulnerable and honest
and this is going to be easier because
you're not looking at each other
watching body positions with each other
oh great
okay so we're zooming now thanks all
right so just
y'all kind of side eye so you don't see
each other all right so lindsay
you walk me through what's going on in
your mind
okay um feels like a bit of a long story
but it's really not
um so xander and i have been dating for
about a year and i
had to we started out being in the same
place
and i had to move away for graduate
school
i'm just finishing up my first year of
my master's
we've had some bumpy patches but we've
made it work this far
and what does bumpy patches mean well
the long distance didn't work out for a
little while
there's a lot of outside influence
that kind of degraded the relationship
for a bit
but we kind of so we we
were not together for a couple months uh
late last year
and we kind of came back to it and said
no you know
we really want to give this not a shot
and we want to
try again because we don't feel like we
were the only ones
influencing the relationship and so
we've
given it another shot and it's been
really good so far okay so to recap
y'all were together you went to grad
school
you ended up you tried to make it work
long term
there was some anytime somebody says
bumpy patches that's
usually really cryptic for like they
stole from me
or they cheated on me with my old
roommate or something like that
so then y'all whatever happened y'all
broke up
and you have these quote unquote outside
influences
is that your friends is that his friends
that your parents who
is that your like y'all buy a dog
together like knuckleheads and then
the dog likes one of you more than the
other what's that what's the outside
influences
my parents specifically my mom
and a few of my friends that
i have just been very negative
about the whole thing negative about him
because he's a bum or negative because
it's just so long distance and why are
you tying yourself down so young
and you're in grad school now and and
all that
um
negative because they
seem to think that xander is
controlling and manipulative and
not a good person and we come from very
different backgrounds
and my family is
not supportive of that at all
and just that they
see that they think we don't have very
much in common
and that he's a bad influence and all of
these things that
i don't believe are true at all okay but
they're very
loud about it so that's always my first
question when someone says
my friends think he's controlling and
manipulative my first question is always
well is he so you're saying no he's a
great influence on you he's not
controlling your manipulative
and he seeks
to he seeks the best for you
yes okay awesome and by the way i didn't
ask that y'all married
engaged where where you are relationally
uh we're
talking about getting engaged okay so
what what's how long have you been
dating including the breakup
um it was a year
in march okay all right all right so
you have you said i love you yet
oh yes oh yeah
that's the most affirmative thing you've
said so far um
all right so oh yeah so you love this
guy
your parents think he's manipulative and
controlling he's the worst your friends
think he's
just dragging you along for a ride but i
love
him and then you're going to grad school
y'all broke up
and has there been any infidelity here
no okay um only one person answered that
xander
has there been any infidelity here no
there hasn't
promised no promise pinky swear to both
of y'all
you think he swear all right something
bad will happen to you if you're lying
okay
so probably not but whatever yeah no
she'll kick my ass
that too all right so um
all right so xander you tell me paint me
a picture here what's going on
so uh throughout pretty much the entire
year or 15 months that we've been dating
it's felt like almost all of our big
fights that we have
have come from this outside influence
you keep you keep talking about i'm
talking about outside influence based on
what she was talking about
mostly her mother and one of her close
friends okay yeah
let's don't call like y'all are
referring to her mother
like um like she's like a political
state
you know what i mean like the government
no she's mom so let's just start calling
her mom okay
we want to humanize this quote unquote
outside influence all right so
her mom and a friend or two um are
really been
pressing on your girlfriend lindsay all
right so go ahead
yeah so it's felt like uh her mom and
one of her best friends have been
trying to speak into her life and change
her opinion on me
okay none of the reasons that either of
us have heard from either of them
have been it have seemed like a good
enough reason to
hate me and i
typically wouldn't care too much about
other people's opinions of me
in that way except for the fact that it
is making it hard for lindsay and i to
just
be ourselves and have our own life
so you will never just be yourselves and
have your own life
there's always going to be other people
involved in this thing right
so that is a as a goal isn't a real
objective but also people pleasing
is not healthy either right so why
why does her mom think you're
manipulative and controlling
so like if me and you were just hanging
out fishing
having a beer why and i was like dude
why does her mom hate you so
much what would your answer to that be
it seems to me like lindsay's mom
has a view on how lindsay's life should
look
and if it doesn't look exactly like that
this is based on
what what i've talked to her mom about
what i've talked to lindsay about
and it's just what i've seen from their
interactions as well
it feels like if lindsay's life isn't
exactly as a mom
looks she freaks out
so her mom has a picture of what she
want her her her pretty little
daughter's life to look like
and it's not you incorrect
whether it's because i didn't grow up in
agriculture or
because i'm not done with school yet or
any of the other reasons that she's
given
gotcha okay so i've got a close friend
whose wife grew up
more ag related
and he grew up in the city and that's
caused some significant tension among
family because there's a culture around
ag
this is like you'll hear things like
this is who we are right
and then folks from a city or suburbs
might not speak in that in those terms
sometimes they do i've never heard
someone to be like you know what we're a
suburb family like i've never really
heard that
but i have heard we're a like
this is us this is who we are we're
farming people we are outside people we
are
filling the blank people right um
so why have you stuck it out
because the amount the picture that
lindsey and i have seen and talked about
is the clearest picture that i've ever
seen in my life
whenever i talk to god about it he's
told me to stay
and uh i've we've
broken up a couple of times um
she's broken up with me i've broken up
with her and typically when i've
ended it or wanted to it just it felt
like i'm
beating a drum that's not being heard
and the reason i've come back and the
reason she's come back i think
is because we've seen that change in
each other and ourselves
and uh and there's also another
wrench that came into play recently
um i went up to visit her for her
birthday in april at the beginning of
april
i flew up there and we found out a
couple weeks ago
that we're having a kid
and there's another little wrench yep
a little yeah guys lead with that
what are you doing wow
how'd you leave that one out all right
this this is like the big reveal
show i feel like we're on a game show
now and then at the end you're gonna be
like and by the way
um all right so
wow yeah that's a good one so does that
accelerate your plans for
getting married yes
okay and that's been a
talking play between us that we don't
necessarily see eye to eye on
okay uh in my opinion
it does accelerate those plans we
made a um we made a mistake in having
that happen before
we were necessarily ready for it even
though we'll never be fully ready for it
but right and in my
opinion knowing how we feel about each
other and knowing what we want in life
as well as being able to start our own
family
all that points to for me is
let's start this thing uh and um i know
lindsay's a little
uh a little more hesitant on it than i
am but
how old are you xander i'm 23.
okay so this is just two dudes hanging
out for a second
on a little side conversation never
refer
to parenting or your wife's future as
let's do this thing
don't refer to anything about her as
quote unquote this thing
just that's just hashtag um just saying
okay so now we're back to a regularly
scheduled program
all right so let me recap
and then we can kind of get to the core
here
um lindsay you love this dude
xander you love this girl you have been
together 15 months you've had some
breakups here and there
um i'll call them like knucklehead of
breakups y'all are both young
and mom does not think that xander's
the guy for you you've got a friend
who probably has matching outfits i
don't know why that matters
all my friends have matching outfits i
just felt wanted i want to say something
mean about your friend without saying it
to me
um she doesn't like him either and
it's gonna say she has sparkly things on
her boots or whatever so
she doesn't like him and
you're in grad school he's finishing his
undergrad degree and
surprise now you're having a baby
so i guess the drum roll please how can
i help
i guess what it boils down to what we
both want
is how do we make sure that
we are making the right choices
for our little family that we've now
started
how do we know that what we're deciding
to do
is the right thing for us
without everybody else trying to
speak into it and tell us what we need
to be doing with our kid
oh man okay that's a million dollar
question that's a great question
so i'm gonna give you the good news and
the bad news at the same time
okay how do you know what you're doing
is right you don't
but you will always know if you do it
together that you'll be there with each
other
and so answering the question of are
y'all going to be in relationship with
one another here that
you are in a relationship with each
other for the rest of your lives
starting now okay
whether you choose to get married
whether you choose to stay boyfriend or
girlfriend whether you choose to live in
different states i've got some opinions
on all that
but y'all are officially in a
relationship forever
okay and so the quicker you can wrap
your head around
that that other people don't get a say
into that
it's an is you're having a kid okay
you made a human congratulations made a
made a human
so you're in it together now what other
people's
influence can be whether they're going
to support you in that
whether they are going to walk away from
you guys whether they're going to
abandon you or they're going to judge
you or they're going to cheer and yeah
they get to choose all of that not y'all
what you all get to choose is what kind
of ecosystem kind of environment are
y'all going to create
so that this kid learns what love is
and learns that they have value and
learns how to be a good
citizen a good person and hopefully a
good mom or husband or dad or
brother or sister in the future
right but y'all are in it now
how does that sound just that stark like
this is happening
lindsay why is that making you cry um
hormones question mark do i didn't hear
you what
hormones and on this show there's one
thing we don't talk about and it's that
i will not respond i'll just say high
five lindsay
take a dive man take a dive yeah yeah
okay so
why does that make you cry
[Music]
i guess it just kind of
it's comforting to know that
i'm not doing this by myself that i have
a partner in xander awesome
and but
we get to do
this raise this kid together yeah so
xander when you hear that that the idea
that you're in this too gives her peace
how do you feel that makes me really
happy
awesome especially with everything
that's been going on
i just wanted to have peace and feel
safe
okay so here's a couple of quick points
of clarification
um you're in grad school how long's your
program lindsay
uh two years and you just finished year
one
okay um are you gonna stay in that state
that you're in are you going to move
back
that depends on where i get a job after
school awesome
so xander are you still in undergrad
right what year are you
so i did two years of mechanical
engineering i had a lot of
issues with my mindset and who i was at
that time
don't care about any of that where are
you headed i don't care where you've
been where are you i'm
right now the plan for me is to get
lindsay through
the rest of her grad school uh make sure
our kids safe and happy and healthy
and then we'll and finish mine i love i
love that
mechanical engineering those do not have
to be mutually exclusive
i do think with the amount of money that
we're able to make right now uh
that seems like the uh
really one of the only ways to do it
essentially so
if i'm you i'll i'll let you i think
there's ways to do it but i will
that's that's your different phone call
the most important thing is
that you've got your priorities straight
and so i'm high-fiving you
okay if i'm you i am
the second this semester is over i am
moving to wherever she is
right i'm gonna get a the cheapest crap
comically crappy apartment i can and i'm
gonna start working 17 jobs
right yeah the job interview lined up uh
this afternoon
that video interview set up for
outstanding
high five okay um you're doing it right
now have you all told mom yet
yeah how'd that go about the parents
though okay how'd that go
real real quick how'd it go great okay
it wasn't great
how about how about your parents xander
my parents are very supportive of us uh
they're obviously a little disappointed
that this happened before we're done
with school
but they know that they can't do
anything about it no one can other than
give
us and a kid the best uh environment
moving forward
awesome so and lindsay
your mom was devastated and dramatic and
oh my little girl and all that
yeah for a while it's getting better now
awesome incrementally
so that's been my experience that the
closer she comes to
getting to hold her grandbaby the more
she begins to soften
the more your boundaries are firm and
strong
and this is what we me and xander are
gonna do for our kid
um this is what this is gonna look like
the more she will come around to it or
she'll opt out but
most of the time people opt in
and man when that when she sees that
grandkid things melt
or she turns bananas who knows
i'm going to live in the optimism that
when she sees you guys standing up tall
you finishing up school xander you
working 17 jobs
and then another one on top of that to
create a
well of financial reserve for this
family
for her grandkid that's awesome that is
fantastic
here's what you should not expect going
forward
you should not expect to be left alone
you're going to get so much stupid dumb
obnoxious ridiculous unasked for advice
over the next year year and a half two
years
okay most of the time that's people
trying to love you the best they know
how
they're just trying okay um you can say
thanks so much for sharing or
i prefer not to talk about that right
now let's talk about this
and you let people have their boundaries
both of you have to get a couple of
people that you trust
and that support you and that you
love to speak into you okay xander
you're gonna have to get some men in
your life
that you trust that will say hey idiot
you got to be doing
better harder why are you hanging out
with us you got a pregnant wife at home
get your butt home
and make sure she's doing okay right
lindsay you're gonna have to have people
who
will honor and love xander for the hard
worker that he is
his i mean his impulse is great i've
talked to people like well i'm just
gonna finish school and then in two
years
i'll move no i mean i'm quitting it all
and we're gonna i'm gonna put what i was
going to do on the line because now i
got a kid and i got other
responsibilities are more important
that tells me at least out of the gate
the guy's got some level of character
okay you're on the right path are you
going to make everybody happy here no
are y'all gonna do whatever comes your
way together yes
the question you all need to answer is
are we gonna get married out of the gate
what's our relationship gonna
our romantic relationship gonna look
like it can get real easy to turn this
next couple of
six or seven or eight or nine months
into um
job tasks and you lose each other in
this and you're all going to need each
other
and so i want you guys immediately
to get a relationship counselor
immediately
to work through the relational aspects
of this because there's going to be some
job stuff you got to earn money
you got to be healthy you got to sleep
you got to get your assignments turned
in
but there's also something else going
along this way which is
lindsay you can't go through this by
yourself your bodies are going to change
your hormones
allegedly change i'm just kidding
everything's going to change for you
and you need somebody alongside you
saying i love you i love you i love you
and xander you're about to be a dad
everything you know is about to get
turned upside down slapped up flipped up
and reversed
and you need lindsey walking alongside
you saying
i'm so glad you're with me and y'all
just gonna have to learn some new
schools
new tools and some new skills
y'all are in it so thank you so much for
telling us about this i think you're on
the right track i think you're doing the
right things
i'm proud of you guys for saying okay
this happened now what's next
and xander i don't want you to ever
forget that the moment lindsay heard
xander's all in
she wept publicly
and lindsey i don't want you to forget
that xander said all right everything
stops i'm all in
i'm all in we would have done it in a
different order
if we'd planned it that way but we
didn't it happened and so here we go
i'm gonna recommend man y'all been
together a year
you said you love him he's your guy you
said you love her she's your guy
i'd recommend y'all get married but i
want you all to meet with somebody
and go through that process make sure
you're all on the same page relationally
okay best of luck to you let us know
after the baby's born how we can
um cheer you guys on and if you got a
photo or something send it to us and
we'll show
everybody the picture after baby's born
grandparents mother's in law
when you find out that you're about to
have an unplanned grandkid you got two
choices
to grieve the fact that your picture is
going to be different and then be all in
on that kid
all in on your kid you remember how
lonely it was when you're pregnant
or all in on that grandkid or you can
grieve that your picture's going to be
different you can throw a temper tantrum
and starve that new grandkid of their
grandparents starve your child
of the season they need their parents
the most
right and you get to lecture by the way
kids get over yourselves let your
parents lecture you and give you advice
that's just what they do that's cool
but guys rally around each other we're
all in it together okay
thank you so much for the call lindsey
and xander we're high-fiving you
make good choices stay in school don't
do drugs all that after school special
stuff good job